[Music]
I'm not sure if you're familiar with
Andrew yang yes I am so there's a
candidate for president of the United
States whose platform Andrew yang is
based in part around job loss due to
automation and also in addition the need
perhaps of universal basic income to
support jobs that are folks who lose
their job due to automation so what are
your thoughts about his concerns him as
a candidate his ideas in general I think
his thinking is generally in the right
direction but his approach as a
presidential candidate
may be a little bit had at the time I
think the displacements will happen but
will they happen soon enough for people
to agree to vote for him the
unemployment numbers are not very high
yet and I think you know he and I have
the same challenge if I want to
theoretically convince people this is an
issue and he wants to become the
president people have to see how can
this be the case one and employment
numbers are low so that is the challenge
I do agree with him on the displacement
issue I think the main issue is
retraining so people need to be incented
not by just giving a monthly $2,000
check or $1,000 check and do whatever
they want because they don't have to
know how to know what to retrain to go
into what type of a job and guidance is
needed and Retraining is needed because
historically with technology revolutions
when routine jobs were displaced new
routine jobs came up but with a eye on
automation
the whole point is replacing all routine
jobs eventually and AI will create jobs
but it won't create routine jobs because
if it creates routine jobs why wouldn't
a I just do it so therefore the people
who are losing the jobs are losing
routine jobs the jobs that are becoming
available
non-routine jobs so the social stipend
needs to be put in place is for the
routine workers who lost their jobs to
be retrained and then take out a job
that will last for that person's
lifetime
you